[Musique]
étranger
étranger [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
étranger Je
ne sais pas avec certitude ce que c'est mais
quelque chose est arrivé sur le côté du
bateau
Je ne sais pas ce que j'ai vu
mais c'était étrange et  c'était troublant
quelque chose a attiré le coin de l'œil
mais définitivement euh quelque chose était là nous nous sommes
retournés nous le regardions
et c'était un cou et une tête noirs
c'est totalement moi c'est probablement l'
interprétation la plus proche de tout ce que j'ai jamais
vu ça  a été mis en place qui
remplit la facture de ce que j'ai vu de
grandes bosses étrangères
dépassant de cette surface calme du lac
Immobile
et ils ont juste coulé très lentement sous
la surface du lac
ce que j'ai vu était une sorte de vert brun verdâtre
et il n'avait pas  toutes les caractéristiques autres
que ce genre de
chose post-regard arrondie ce
que nous avons vu était un cou noir et la tête de
quelque chose
ce sont la taille des
ailerons qui sont sortis de l'eau cette
taille cette taille
quatre
jobbies qui étaient violets et c'était
toute cette couleur rose
[Musique]
journaliste explorateur scientifique
Touristes fluviaux est
[Musique]
étranger [
Musique] [Musique
]
étranger [
Musique] étranger [Musique]
étranger
[Musique]
Burlington
dans les années 1990 il y a eu une rafale d'
observations de champions il y a plusieurs livres sur  champion
est sorti beaucoup d'articles de journaux dont
certains que j'écrivais et les gens se sont
manifestés tout le temps avec le champion voyant
ce tableau a été mis en place dans les années 1980,
il a été conçu à l'origine pour être
une sorte de tableau évolutif qui cataloguerait
tous ceux qui ont déjà  vu le champion
étranger
début décembre, nous revenions de
la région du lac George le long du Lakeshore
en dessous de Port Henry à Southport Henry
dimanche après-midi et donc je regardais
par la fenêtre et tout à coup je vois
ce truc en forme de poteau alors je me suis tourné vers  Bob
et moi disons qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc qui ressemble à un poteau là-
bas et quand je regarde en arrière,
il était parti, il n'y avait pas de poteau mais il y
avait des cercles concentriques d'eau, vous
savez, comme de grosses ondulations rondes qui
sortent et les poteaux ne disparaissent pas comme
ça je  je ne pouvais rien voir le lac
était plat il n'y avait rien
mais ce n'était pas mon imagination je crois
au chant
o Village de Port Henry considerica
champ
ions
[Music]
champ
pourquoi devriez-vous venir à Port Henry bien je
veux dire vous tous  ce qu'il faut faire, c'est regarder la
région,
cela ressemble à un village européen sur une
colline, c'est absolument
spectaculaire et bien sûr, nous avons notre
résident de renommée mondiale, un champion que vous connaissez à ce
jour, même moi-même, vous savez que vous ne pouvez pas
regarder  le lac Champlain sans
chercher
quelque chose là-bas qui peut être
différent
oui presque
[Musique]
étranger [
Musique] [
Musique]
étranger
[Musique]
nous avons acheté notre maison d'été à une vieille
marine vierge qui a parcouru le monde sur
des cargos
et l'un de mes premiers  jours ici, je n'oublierai jamais
cela, nous pêchions dans un
très petit bateau au large de Port Henry ici et
il m'a regardé et il a dit Ron, il y a
des choses très étranges dans ce lac,
cette phrase est restée dans mon esprit et
m'a vraiment hypnotisé et est resté  avec moi depuis
l'âge de 13 ans jusqu'à la fin de la vingtaine lorsque cette
phrase est revenue en jeu et je vais
vous dire ce qui s'est passé en 1981, il
y a eu une rafale d'observations de champions
dans la région du port Henry et je travaillais
comme journaliste  pour l'Albany
New York Times Union, qui est le principal
quotidien d'Albany New York, la
capitale et mes rédacteurs étaient
intéressés à voir tous ces
reportages sur le champion cité à seulement deux
heures au nord d'Albany ce lac majeur le
lac Champlain et j'ai écrit un  série en six parties
relatant La vague d'
activités dans la région du port Henry,
c'était une bonne histoire, mon papier était gros,
donc au moment où j'écrivais l'
article et lorsque les articles ont été publiés,
je me fichais de savoir s'il y avait un
monstre dans  le lac ou pas mais deux ans
plus tard presque jour pour jour, ma perspective a
radicalement changé le
week-end du 4 juillet 1983.
Je pêche avec ma copine Le
lac Champlain est comme du verre
et ma copine est à l'avant du
bateau elle dit Ron qu'est-ce que je fais '  ne
prêtons pas beaucoup d'attention étant silencieux
nous pêchons en essayant d'attraper du poisson dit-elle
dit encore Ron qu'est-ce que c'est et
elle montre du doigt et je regarde où elle
pointe
[Musique]
et nous avons regardé pendant probablement
10 secondes
trois grosses bosses qui ressemblaient à  gros
pneus collant peut-être un pied et
demi hors de l'eau
Immobile
après avoir vu ces trois
grosses bosses hors de l'eau, je
regarde en arrière, je dois conclure même si
je n'ai rien vu depuis et que j'ai
été sur le lac presque tous les  jour au cours des
cinq ou six dernières années en été, vous
devez arriver à la conclusion qu'il
y a quelque chose d'inexpliqué dans le
lac et cela pourrait très bien être dans mon
esprit
une plésiosaura pourrait être quelque chose qui
échappe à toute notre imagination et peut
être là pour  se faire découvrir
champion
étranger
[Musique]
Je pense qu'il ressemble à un gros poisson
un peu comme un dinosaure de la préhistoire
[Musique]
étranger [
Musique]
[Musique]
Je suis le spécialiste de l'éducation scientifique
et nous avons un programme passionnant aujourd'hui
il s'appelle  vaincre
le mystère non résolu
[Musique]
c'est
[Musique] l'
un des éléments de preuve les plus convaincants
que nous ayons est la photographie
que Sandra manncy a prise en 1977.
donc la photographie ressemble beaucoup à ce que
vous disiez à un plésiosaure
[Musique]
quand  elle a d'abord pris cette photo, elle
n'était pas certaine de ce qu'elle avait vu, mais c'était
quelque chose de très dangereux dans son
esprit, elle avait besoin de faire sortir les enfants du
lac où ils nageaient là-bas quand
cette créature est arrivée derrière c'est la
seule photo la  seule
photo claire du champion qui est là-bas
en ce moment
[Music]
La photos
étrangère,
elle a pris la photo au New York Times
et le New York Times l'a apportée à un
analyste qui a déterminé que ce n'était pas une
fraude, c'était '  c'est un faux et le New York
Times a publié la photo elle a depuis été
reproduite dans de nombreux magazines
journaux elle a été dans des spéciaux sur le
champion la photo mancy est considérée comme la
preuve la plus définitive que le champion existe
toujours à l'étranger [Musique] et qui fait partie de ce qui fait
tout cela est excitant, cela montre ce qui ressemble à la
tête d'une créature, cela ressemble à l'un
de ces dinosaures jouets de quand j'étais un
petit enfant et
donc si vous imaginez la tête d'un
brontosaure ou quelque chose comme ça,
ça ressemblerait beaucoup à ça
[Musique]
quand j'ai vu la photo de Sandra mancy pour la première fois,
j'ai pensé qu'elle avait pris une photo
d'un plésiosaure, j'ai pensé que c'était la
preuve absolue que le champion existe
euh, la photo de manchi aurait
été prise dans la région de la baie de misiskoy dans
le nord  une partie du lac cependant
dans la zone que Sandra mancy a rapporté
avoir pris la photo,
l'eau du lac est d'environ 14 à 15 pieds de
profondeur, ce n'est pas très profond, donc une grande
créature aurait du
mal à se cacher dans cette faible
profondeur de mèmes d'eau
merci
une population étrangère sur une longue période il
faudrait probablement 40 ou 50
créatures de type champion ici pour se reproduire et
résister aux rigueurs du temps une très
petite population d'un couple ou d'une
paire ne serait vraiment pas suffisante
[Musique]
existence
les plaisirs ou l'hypothèse c'est une
idée intéressante qui plaît beaucoup
à certaines personnes et elles peuvent imaginer à
quoi cela pourrait ressembler cependant
l'environnement ici n'a pas été très
bon
pour une population persistante de
plésiosaures pour une chose le reste du
monde
vu l'extinction du Plesiosaurus il y a
environ 65 millions d'années donc quand on
parle de l'histoire du lac Champlain il y a
000 ans il faut retenir que c'est
que le Plesiosaurus s'est éteint il y a 65
000 ans
[Musique]
étrangère
La Mer
prenons  un regard sur certains des crypto
ou Cryptids comme on les appelle des animaux
qui ont été là-bas l'un des
premiers était Kraken comme vous le savez peut-être
le serpent de mer géant en ce moment le
calmar géant comme on les appelle Have Eyes
la taille de  assiettes plates ils ont un
bec très pointu
et ce n'est qu'en
2006 que les scientifiques japonais
ont filmé ce calmar géant alors ce qui était
un Cryptid est devenu oui en fait cet animal
est réel et il était dans l'eau à plus de 2 900
pieds
alors que faire  vous pensez maintenant au champion
pourrait-il être un Cryptid pourrait-il être
quelque chose dans l'eau nous ne sommes pas si
sûrs donc je pense que nous trouvons constamment
des choses qui sont dans nos mers dans nos lacs
dans nos océans que nous ne savions pas  étaient
là avant et je pense que les gens se
rapportent à cette information en disant eh
bien si les gens découvrent de nouvelles choses
alors pourquoi ne peuvent-ils pas découvrir un
monstre de lac aussi
[Musique]
voir champion I Je pense juste qu'il y
a des choses
dans ma vision du monde que je crois  nous ne
savons pas tout il y a de la place pour des choses
que nous ne connaissons pas
[Musique]
et donc je me retrouve
parfois à regarder le lac si je lis
ou marche
Je connais des gens qui disent qu'ils ne
croient pas au champion  et ils vous pouvez
les attraper en train de traverser le ferry en
temps étranger [Musique] géologiquement quand la mer était
reliée au lac
pourquoi ne serait-il pas possible que des
créatures marines que nous
n'avons pas connues soient venues  Le
lac Champlain puis adopté leur
existence dans le lac Champlain
on ne sait pas
et c'est intéressant de ne pas savoir
sauf que ce
n'était certainement pas
[Musique]
mon pote disait hey c'est des canards
quelque chose qui nage bien merci non euh
les canards ne nagent pas la nuit et ils charlatan
[Musique]
alors tourne toi qu'est ce que tu vois
un lapin ok fais demi tour je'  je vais
changer la photo
tout de suite tournez que voyez-vous dites
moi
un canard un lapin d'accord
ah d'accord donc en tournant le lapin nos
perceptions ont changé c'est toujours un lapin
vous êtes un peu confus quant à ce que cela
pourrait être c'est amusant  regarder comment
les gens s'assoient là et changent d'avis
pendant la présentation et
commencent à croire que les gens peuvent
dire quelque chose sur le lac sans
savoir exactement ce que cela pourrait être, mais ils
croient qu'il se passe quelque chose
sur le lac
étranger
je  travaillait sur le ferry
Champlain revenant de Port Kent New
York dans l'après-midi chaud d'août et euh
nous étions assis sur le pont
[Musique]
et je lisais et j'ai
levé les yeux et j'ai aperçu ces
deux nageoires qui  sont sortis de l'eau,
les gens qui étaient avec moi assis sur
les bancs du bateau ont tous couru
et ont demandé ce que c'était et j'étais
un membre d'équipage et en tant que membre d'équipage, je
devais le faire après que le deuxième soit sorti
du  l'eau, j'ai dû expliquer que c'est
définitivement Champ,
tout le monde a couru vers le rail et maintenant, tout le
monde Jumping Up Down les enfants
ramassent du pop-corn en le jetant dans
l'alimentation du champion, tout le monde est assez excité
et c'était ma première observation physique
et je crois qu'il y a quelque chose
ici  cela fait partie de l'héritage des lacs du
Vermont
[Musique]
la distance que
j'ai parcourue pour travailler pour le lac Champlain Ferris
en
1980 au printemps 1980 et je fais
beaucoup de kayak aussi ici, je suis souvent assis ici,
donc euh plus ma carrière ici  Je
euh je suis souvent ici et euh c'est un
endroit assez incroyable
euh pas un mauvais bureau
[Musique]
Je me souviens d'un printemps où nous avions des
hautes eaux et du vent et je
travaillais en fait sur le pont et euh le
capitaine que j'étais  en travaillant avec Cindy, nous avons tous les deux
vu ce long
morceau de quelque chose avec une petite chose
comme ça et c'était clairement un
journal, j'ai dit, attendez que quelqu'un
vienne nous demander et bien sûr peut-être que
la semaine suivante, une femme est venue à bord
avec un huit  photo de taille huit par dix de
ce morceau de cosse et elle nous a demandé si
vous l'aviez vu du tout et nous avons dit oui c'est
là-bas sur ce rivage et
c'est un gros morceau donc c'est probablement pour
moi le plus proche que
vous savez que je peux dire  il y avait
quelque chose là-bas qui ressemblait à Tim
euh ou ressemblait à quelque chose d'inhabituel
[Musique]
ce qu'ils voient est un merveilleux
terrain fertile pour la spéculation il y
a beaucoup de gros animaux dans le lac Champlain
mais grand signifie cinq ou six pieds de long
deux mètres peut-être que nous avons  l'esturgeon
l'esturgeon jaune est une chose assez impressionnante
comme une barbue de rivière qui peut être
très grande
et il pourrait aussi y avoir deux ou trois
loutres nageant successivement l'une derrière
l'autre derrière l'autre jouant et
ressemblant à un seul animal
étranger
[Musique]
explications possibles  pour ce que les gens
ont vu qui avait l'air dynamique, ils ont l'air
vivant et cela peut arriver quand euh
le sillage d'un bateau un train de vagues qui
s'appelle le sillage de la proue d'un
bateau qui se déplace euh à travers le lac
qui est une chaîne de notre  train de vagues
qui
traversera le lac et sera
vu par des gens très éloignés du bateau
lui-même
[Musique]
Vidéos du restaurant Legend
oh je suis sur le lac depuis 40 ans euh
nous sommes là tout le temps où nous allons
nous sortons beaucoup de monde et
vous cherchez toujours à chaque fois que vous êtes
sur l'eau vous cherchez toujours un
champion
à un moment donné, quelqu'un va
filmer quelque chose et nous aurons la
preuve que
notre balle est
tampon étranger
[Musique]
mode étranger
alors nous y sommes et c'est là que nous avons
commencé et quand j'étais enfant, nous faisions du
ski nautique ici dans la baie juste
des trucs oh comme ça ouais
il est temps de se lancer chez un skieur nautique
nous vérifions  assurez-vous qu'il va bien, puis je me
suis retourné et j'ai regardé sur le côté
du bateau assurez-vous de regarder devant vous
assurez-vous de ne rien renverser
juste à côté du bateau il y avait
quelque chose qui était vivant
[Musique]
c'est comme ça  de large
cette grosse bosse longue qui était aussi longue que
le bateau ce petit bateau de ski de 16 pieds c'était
un peu déconcertant
quoi qu'il soit vivant et juste en quelque
sorte disparu dans l'eau à l'avant
et à l'arrière du bateau
qu'il conduisait
si nous attrapions la roue tournait autour d'un
tas de ouais ouais comme monter dans les
bateaux comme mais c'est mon tour de monter dans le
bateau, vous pouvez voir où les terres agricoles que la
main droite l'un de ces deux c'est
Arnold Bay
aviez-vous peur de penser ouais  Je veux dire que
vous ne saviez pas ce que c'était
euh ce que
vous savez à quelle fréquence voyez-vous un
poisson plus gros que le bateau dans lequel vous êtes, vous
savez que c'est un peu comme à la sortie
de Jaws l'
avez-vous revu je l'ai fait en tant qu'adulte
euh nous sommes en fait c'était dans ce sac
deux fois ouais mes enfants étaient petits et nous
étions sortis dîner
et c'était une bonne nuit et euh nous
remettions juste parce que nous avions
des baby-sitters et c'était ici sur
en fait dans ce Shore
[  Musique]
nous profitons juste du
temps chaud et de l'appartement commun euh ma
femme dit qu'est-ce que c'est maintenant et parce que
j'avais lu un peu sur champion et
surmonté la peur initiale d'il y a
trop longtemps au lieu de tourner le
la roue et en m'éloignant j'ai tourné la roue nous nous sommes
dirigés vers lui et quoi que
ce soit, il s'éloignait de nous nous nous sommes
déplacés après lui
euh et nous l'avons regardé et il a disparu
et tout d'un coup c'est de l'autre
côté du bateau et  le couple qui était
avec nous un gars disait
euh ben tu sais ce n'est pas Champlin oui c'est
euh quoi que ce soit vivant il
nageait et il s'est éloigné de nous par
ici et il est revenu maintenant il est de ce
côté du bateau
étranger
donc avec tout cela le soir d'une
nuit d'été lorsque vous regardez
le lac et que vous voyez quelque chose dont
vous n'êtes pas tout à fait sûr, pensez au
fait que vous pourriez voir champion
chaque fois que vous avez une conversation à propos de
vous champion  Je verrai des gens se retourner et
vouloir vous parler de cette
créature étonnante, c'est donc une émission très populaire
que nous faisons ici à Echo
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
étranger
[Musique]
ce livre s'appelle
Ed Shankman
dans la vallée du Vermont près d'un lac
appelé Champlain si vous coupez à travers les
bois sur Old Country Lane, vous
arriverez dans une prairie avec un érable
aussi haut qu'une personne peut voir
croyez-vous que ce champion est là-bas  Je
pense qu'il est ouais l'avez-vous déjà vu avez-vous
connu quelqu'un qui pensait avoir
signé dites-
nous le
mari d'une baby-sitter il pensait avoir vu un
champion parce qu'ils ont une belle vue sur
le lac
[Musique]
l'histoire du champion ne remonte pas seulement
à  les années 70 ou les années 80, mais vous savez que vous avez
parlé à des gens avec qui j'ai grandi
avec mon père, vous savez qui ont pêché comme
Champlain, vous savez qu'ils ont vu
quelque chose là-bas qui était
différent, vous savez, même pendant la
saison de pêche blanche, ils le feraient  voyez ces
ombres que
vous connaissez alors qu'elles sont assises dans leurs
baraques à poissons et vous savez que vous
regardez dans votre trou et que vous
vous pêchez tout d'un coup, vous voyez juste
cette ombre sombre que
vous savez remplir les trous puis
vous cogner  peut voir à nouveau là-dedans, donc je
crois absolument que
quelque chose là-bas et encore une fois,
vous savez pendant que vous visitez Port
Henry, vous savez, je suis certain que vous connaissez
la plupart des zones du village de Port Henry,
vous pouvez voir le lac Champlain
donc vous allez regarder vers l'Est et
vous allez chercher
notre champion résident le plus célèbre Port
Henry Village
[Musique]
la journée des champions a proposé l'
activité de numéros pour La Familia le champion annuel de Philadelphie
[Musique]
accompagné de Samuel de Champlain
étranger
[Musique] [Musique]
deepere
[Musique]
est
la législature que
nous avons lancée Champs Trading Post parce que
nous avons découvert qu'il n'y avait vraiment personne
qui vendait des accessoires de champion
à vendre pour des souvenirs, nous avons donc développé
notre propre ligne qui comprend t  -des chemises et des
chapeaux et des verres à liqueur et des tasses qui ont
Champ sur eux, ils ont vraiment très
bien réussi pour nous, nous constatons que cela a vraiment
aidé notre entreprise à avoir le nom de
Champs et à attirer des gens dans
les gens qui viennent, ils disent oh nous avons regardé
partout  pour les choses de champion, nous avons
du mal à les trouver, ils sont
ravis de pouvoir trouver ce qu'ils
recherchent pour ramener quelque chose à la maison pour
leurs enfants ou juste un souvenir d'être
ici à la recherche d'un champion
[Musique]
après toi '  J'ai passé tout ce temps
à chercher un champion, il y a quelques
sites historiques intéressants qui pourraient vous
intéresser, l'un d'eux est à Crown
Point, qui est juste au sud d'ici
et il y a là-bas de vieilles ruines du vieux fort
et vous pouvez simplement vous promener  à travers
quelque chose d'un peu plus structuré est
Fort Ticonderoga qui est un
site historique, ils font des reconstitutions des
différentes batailles qui étaient que Fort
ticonder était impliqué dans
le genre de personnes qui viennent dans notre
magasin sont des gens qui connaissent le
champion Legend sont intrigués par  il a
ses propres histoires, certains ont beaucoup de
questions dont ils n'ont jamais entendu parler
et c'est juste amusant d'entendre les différentes
histoires et
vous savez parler aux gens de ce qu'ils
pensent qu'est le champion
et à la fin de la journée, s'asseoir avec  un
verre de vin sur le pont, puis juste
Joy le soleil sur le lac et peut-être que
dans ces derniers instants, vous verrez le
champion au loin
Fort Henry est un endroit magnifique, il fait
partie des plus beaux endroits de la Terre  Le
lac Champlain est un lac incroyable à
voir et à apprécier et je pense que les
résidents de Port Henry sont incroyablement
chanceux d'avoir une telle beauté et une telle
majesté dans leur arrière-cour
[Musique]
si vous venez au Vermont près d'un lac
appelé Champlain et que vous coupez à travers le
bois sur Old Country Lane, il y a une
chance que vous voyiez mon ami Champion
me jouer heureux et libre près du vieil
érable
et c'est la fin
[Music]
team [
Music]
exploratory
Predators
maintenant le champion fait partie de qui nous sommes Champion
New York et  également au Québec très
vénéré comme une sorte de symbole emblématique
de notre région, il y a aussi des croustilles
qui sont appelées champion il y a différents
champions de lave-auto et bien sûr il y a
beaucoup de différents types de monuments le
monstre du lac pour
euh l'équipe de baseball ici est  Champ
[Musique]
Lain est un lac
puissant Dynamique plein de surprises
il y a quelque chose de mystérieux et de sauvage
dans le lac Champlain
à chaque fois que je suis près du lac
que je pêche ou que je navigue avec
ma boîte à pêche je porte un appareil photo
avec moi, je suis peut-être la prochaine personne qui
prétend avoir l'image définitive du
monstre du lac Champlain,
mais vous êtes toujours à la recherche de cela pour le
champion et il y a de fortes chances que lorsque vous êtes
ici en visite, vous allez les repérer,
j'en suis un  des gens qui ont réellement vu
champion
je n'en ai pas peur
si tu y crois vraiment ou si tu veux juste le
changer
tu sais juste tu sais tu ne sais jamais
je suis sérieux
[Musique]
je ne suis pas prêt à fermer le livre sur  champion
jamais
je crois tout ce que j'ai vu tout ce que
j'ai entendu et surtout
avec cette observation personnelle de quelque chose
de physique que je pourrais en fait dire oui
c'est pourquoi vous savez que je suis ici
pour partager ceci pour vous faire savoir que cela fonctionne
bien Champs et  plus nous avons besoin de plus de champions
certainement
tant de gens ont une si grande
affection pour l'idée d'une
créature de Champlain et donc je pense que
leur meilleur habitat
pour le champion et où le champion vit vraiment
est dans le cœur et l'esprit de
beaucoup de gens
[Musique]
merci  vous
étranger
[Musique]